Muchos la consideran como una de las mejores
ciudades para vivir de todo Estados Unidos. Y
no solo eso, la ciudad del emblemático Golden
Gate también es considerada como una de las
mejores ciudades de todo el mundo para que
los jóvenes puedan trabajar y prosperar.
Y, ¿qué queréis qué os diga? Seguro
que no te sorprende, al fin y al cabo,
además de tener un sector tecnológico muy
fuerte, esta ciudad está también justo
al lado de Silicon Valley, el mayor
HUB tecnológico de todo el planeta.
Y, además, también cuenta con un potente
centro financiero de talla mundial.
Por eso no puede extrañarnos que
la Bahía de San Francisco se sitúe
como una de las áreas metropolitanas más
ricas y con más millonarios del mundo.
De hecho, tan solo la ciudad, sin contar su zona
metropolitana, tiene un PIB de más de $200.000
millones. Lo que, por ejemplo, equivale a toda
la economía de un país como Grecia. No está mal.
Con todas estas referencias, casi,
casi que podríamos llegar a pensar
que San Francisco es algo así como
el cielo en la tierra, ¿verdad?
Pues, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
nada más lejos de la realidad. Si fuera así,
no estaríamos haciendo este video. Es cierto,
San Francisco tiene mucho que ofrecer,
pero desde hace ya unos cuantos años la
ciudad ha estado perdiendo atractivo.
Y, ojo, porque no son pocas
las personas que temen que
pueda seguir el mismo camino que en
su día Detroit tomó hacia el abismo.
Por eso la pregunta es: ¿Cuáles son exactamente
los problemas que castigan a esta ciudad? ¿Cómo
es posible que San Francisco parezca estar
siguiendo los mismos pasos que Detroit? En este
vídeo vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas,
pero antes, antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1 (1.
CRECIENDO POR TENDENCIAS)
Fundado en 1776 por colonos españoles que
construyeron en la Bahía una misión, la misión de
San Francisco, en honor a San Francisco de Asís,
el enclave comenzó a prosperar a principios
del siglo XIX con el nombre de Yerba Buena.
Sin embargo, cuando Estados Unidos
se lo arrebató a México en 1846 la
renombró otra vez como San Francisco. Pese a todo,
seguía siendo un pequeño poblado sin mucho
interés aparente… Hasta que apareció el oro.
La fiebre del oro hizo que la población de
San Francisco pasara de 1000 habitantes en
1848 a más 25 000 en poco más de un año. Este
fue el primer gran despegue de la ciudad.
El segundo se produjo con la Segunda
Guerra Mundial. Aquí se estableció
una de las grandes bases de la
flota del Pacífico y una enorme
industria ligada al suministro de
munición y equipos para la Armada.
Luego el tercer gran despegue tuvo que
ver por supuesto con la revolución de las
puntocom a finales del siglo XX y principios
del XXI. Teniendo Silicon Valley a un paso,
naturalmente, San Francisco se convirtió
en la gran ciudad de referencia para los
inversores, ingenieros, científicos
y emprendedores de todo el mundo.
Asimismo, durante las últimas décadas San
Francisco, un área metropolitana con casi
5 millones de habitantes, ha sido la
cuna de grandes movimientos sociales,
como las protestas contra la guerra
de Vietnam, los famosos Hippies o la
lucha por los derechos de las minorías,
especialmente los de las personas LGTB.
En otras palabras, San Francisco ha sido y sigue
siendo una de las ciudades más ricas e influyentes
de todo el mundo. Tanto desde un punto de vista
económico como político, social y cultural.
C1 (“San Francisco es una ciudad de
locos, habitada en su mayor parte por
gente perfectamente loca” – Rudyard
Kipling en American Notes (1891)
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, ahora toda
esta historia de prosperidad está contra
las cuerdas. La imagen de San Francisco se está
deteriorando a toda velocidad… Y la pregunta es,
¿por qué? ¿Qué demonios está pasando
en la loca La Ciudad de la Bahía?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T2 (SAN FRANCISCO, LA VERDADERA GOTHAM CITY)
No es ningún secreto que en las grandes ciudades,
por norma general, se cometen bastante
más crímenes que en las pequeñas urbes
o en los entornos rurales. Y desde luego, San
Francisco no es diferente ni lo ha sido nunca.
Por ejemplo, durante la fiebre del
oro, entre los años 1850 y 1856,
se produjeron en la ciudad 1.400 asesinatos.
Incluso en 1975 en esta misma ciudad se produjo un
intento de asesinato contra
el expresidente Gerald Ford.
Sin embargo, los últimos años han sido,
o mejor dicho, están siendo una locura.
Por ejemplo, entre el año 2014 y el año 2017
los casos de robo sin violencia se más que
duplicaron hasta rozar los 75.000. Digamos que la
salida de la gran crisis del 2008 fue muy dura.
Luego las cosas empezaron a mejorar, pero desde
el 2020 la criminalidad se ha vuelto a disparar.
Y, no, no fue por la pandemia, sino
por una nueva estrategia política:
la estrategia del exfiscal del distrito de
San Francisco, [Cheisa Budín] Chesa Boudin.
Desde su elección en 2020, [Budín]
Boudin prometió ser más flexible con
quienes cometieran delitos menores y no violentos.
Es decir, básicamente, se dio manga ancha y el
resultado fue un auténtico desastre. De repente,
los ciudadanos de San Francisco se
encontraron con un fiscal que permitía
que criminales reincidentes volvieran a
las calles sin ningún tipo de sanción.
Por ejemplo, podía darse el caso de que
una persona fuera pillada in fraganti
cometiendo algún delito menor, que tuviera
un historial enorme y que, sin embargo,
estuviera segura de que gracias a Boudin no le
pasaría absolutamente nada. A las pocas horas
estaría completamente libre. Y la pregunta
que seguro, seguro muchos os estáis haciendo
es ¿en qué demonios estaba pensando este
fiscal? Pues, entre otras cosas, en esto:
C2 (“Un porcentaje significativo de las personas
que venden drogas en San Francisco proceden de
Honduras. Debemos ser conscientes del impacto
que tienen nuestras intervenciones... Algunos
de estos jóvenes han sido obligados a traficar
aquí bajo pena de muerte. Algunos de ellos tienen
familiares en Honduras que han sufrido o
sufrirán daños si no siguen pagando a los
traficantes" - Boudin en una reunión virtual
del Ayuntamiento de San Francisco en 2020.)
Digamos que la idea era facilitar la reinserción
y de paso aliviar la presión que
sufría el sistema penitenciario.
El problema es que ni contaba
con los recursos suficientes
ni la estrategia se implantó nada bien.
La situación llegó a ser tan salvaje que
en 2022 se estimó que los ciudadanos de
San Francisco tenían una probabilidad de
1 entre 16 de sufrir un crimen violento
o contra su propiedad. Y eso, eso es
lo que explica noticias como esta:
N1(11 de abril de 2023: La crisis de la
delincuencia en San Francisco, en el punto
de mira tras el cierre de Whole Foods. Newsweek)
Efectivamente, amigos, la crisis de inseguridad
que ha estado experimentando la ciudad
ha forzado incluso a que las tiendas
tengan que modificar sus horarios
para evitar robos o, como en el
caso de la cadena de supermercados
Whole Foods, directamente cerrar.
De hecho, desde su apertura en
marzo de 2022 los robos en el
establecimiento fueron tan frecuentes
que el negocio dejó de ser rentable.
Claro que pese a todo, la inseguridad no ha
sido el único problema que Whole Foods señaló
como motivo para echar el cierre. Había otro
problema, ¿Tenéis alguna idea? Pues… Atentos.
T3 (EPIDEMIA… ¿SIN VIRUS?)
Hace ya tiempo que Estados Unidos levantó
las restricciones de entrada en el país
para las personas no vacunadas contra la Covid-19.
Desde luego este virus ya no tiene nada
que ver con lo que fue en 2020 y 2021.
Pero… ¿Y si os dijera que ahora Estados
Unidos está sufriendo su propia epidemia?
Ya sé lo que estaréis pensando:
por favor, no más enfermedades,
dadnos un respiro. Tranquilos, que esta
vez no os vamos a hablar de ningún virus.
Lo que está azotando a todo el país y a San
Francisco de forma especial es una epidemia
muy particular: la de las drogas, y
más concretamente la de los opioides.
Como seguro que ya muchos sabéis, los opioides
son drogas derivadas de la planta del opio.
Muchas de ellas se usan como fármacos: la
oxicodona o la morfina son los ejemplos más
claros. Ambas se usan para tratar todo
tipo de dolores, pero, por desgracia,
también han caído en el mercado negro y se han
convertido en la causa de graves adicciones.
Pero no son ni la oxicodona ni la morfina las
que están creando el caos, sino otra droga de
la que muchos, seguro, seguro que ya habéis oído
hablar en los últimos tiempos: el fentanilo.
Desarrollado en 1959 e introducido en Estados
Unidos en 1960 como un anestésico intravenoso,
el fentanilo ha sido un fármaco
usado habitualmente por médicos
para aliviar dolores después de cirugías
o derivados de patologías como el cáncer.
Sin embargo, el auge en las calles de
esta droga 50 veces más potente que
la heroína y 100 veces más potente que
la morfina no llegó hasta el año 2011,
cuando siendo una opción infinitamente
más barata que la heroína empezó a ganar
cuota de mercado. El problema es
que también es mucho más mortal.
(Para que os hagáis una idea, en los
dos primeros años en el mercado negro,
entre 2011 y 2012, el fentanilo causó la muerte
por sobredosis de 5.200 personas. Y en 2022,
según datos del CDC, unas 70.000
personas fueron víctimas de esta
droga que es mezclada habitualmente
con otras como la metanfetamina.
Sí, sí, lo habéis oído bien,
70.000 víctimas mortales.)
Queridos amigos, el abuso de los opioides y
en especial del fentanilo ha provocado una
enorme crisis con decenas y decenas de miles de
víctimas y un impacto económico multimillonario.
(Un informe del Congreso dice que la crisis de los
opiáceos le costará a EE.UU. casi 1,5
billones de dólares en 2020. Reuters)
Tan solo en 2020, un 7% del PIB ¡De locos!
Por eso, la administración Biden ha
empezado a tomar cartas en el asunto.
Y veréis, esta droga no se
produce dentro del país,
sino que es fabricada con químicos llegados
desde China por cárteles mexicanos que luego
la introducen en Estados Unidos. Estamos
hablando sobre todo del Cártel de Sinaloa.
Pues bien, la administración Biden
ya le ha pedido a China que sea más
estricta y tenga más control sobre
sus exportaciones de químicos,
al tiempo que está trabajando para
incrementar la cooperación con México.
Ahora bien, ¿cómo creéis que han
reaccionado ambos países? Pues,
por ahora, China se ha comprometido a
ayudar a Estados Unidos, sin embargo,
no parece estar cumpliendo lo prometido.
De hecho, la mayoría de los analistas están
seguros de que China está interesado
en que esta epidemia no se termine.
¿Y México? AMLO seguro que
está cumpliendo, ¿no? Pues,
desgraciadamente, prefiere
echar balones fuera. Fijaos:
N3 (El presidente mexicano achaca la crisis
del fentanilo en EEUU a la "falta de abrazos"
entre las familias. Andrés Manuel López
Obrador achaca a la falta "de abrazos"
las 70.000 muertes anuales por sobredosis
atribuidas al opioide sintético. The Guardian)
La situación es devastadora en todo
Estados Unidos, y particularmente
en San Francisco. La perla de la Bahía es
una de las ciudades más afectadas. Fijaos.
Y sí, como seguramente os estéis imaginando,
el fentanilo es el mayor responsable de esta
tragedia. Para ser exactos, esta sustancia fue
la culpable de 7 de cada 10 víctimas mortales.
Y las cosas no están mejorando.
N4 (Las muertes por sobredosis en San
Francisco alcanzan las 200 en tres meses:
"Una auténtica vergüenza”. El aumento del 41%
se produce cuando la ciudad ha cerrado un centro
de asistencia que disponía de Narcan y permitía
el consumo supervisado de drogas. The Guardian)
De hecho, ¿recordáis el supermercado que cerró
en San Francisco por la inseguridad? Pues en
septiembre de 2022 se encontraron a una persona
fallecida por fentanilo y metanfetamina en los
cuartos de baño. Y la entrada estaba siempre
atestada de personas consumiendo estas sustancias.
Así que ya lo veis, tanto la inseguridad
como los narcóticos están haciendo que la
que ha sido calificada por muchos como la
ciudad más bonita de Estados Unidos se esté
sumiendo en un oscuro abismo. Pero ¿pensáis
que hemos terminado? Pues… No, nada de eso.
Atentos.
T4 (EL ÉXODO URBANO)
Si vivís en alguna ciudad
grande como Madrid, Chicago,
Roma o París, os habréis dado cuenta de que los
alquileres están por las nubes. Sin embargo,
según el Foro Económico Mundial,
ninguna de estas cuatro ciudades,
por ejemplo, se encuentra entre las
ciudades más caras en las que vivir.
Pero ¿sabéis cuál sí está
en el top 10? Efectivamente,
San Francisco. Y os preguntaréis,
¿esto a qué se debe? Pues, sobre todo,
a un problema en concreto: los
altos costes de las viviendas
Por supuesto, los altos precios de
las viviendas no vienen de la nada.
Por lo general, se producen porque la
oferta es mucho menor que la demanda.
Y este es, sin duda, el caso de San Francisco.
Por ejemplo, la ciudad de Austin, Texas,
que tiene una población similar a San Francisco,
ha construido 133.000 viviendas nuevas desde el
año 2010. ¿Sabéis cuántas se han construido
en la ciudad de la Bahía? Apenas 37.500.
Como os podéis imaginar, esto ha hecho que
tanto los alquileres como los precios de las
casas se disparen… Y la situación ha llegado
a tal punto que ya está afectando
al tejido productivo de la ciudad.
De hecho, en San Francisco se ha construido
solamente una casa por cada 8 trabajos nuevos
en la última década. Y con las oficinas ha
ocurrido tres cuartas partes de lo mismo.
Y si creíais que la situación no podía empeorar,
la pandemia de la covid-19 ha puesto patas
arriba a la economía de la ciudad. ¿Por qué?
Pues por una simple razón: el teletrabajo.
N5 (San Francisco duplica con creces su estimación
de trabajo permanente a distancia.SFStandard)
Efectivamente, los altos precios de las
oficinas han hecho que el teletrabajo se
haya puesto de moda en San Francisco desde
el año 2020. De hecho, algunas estimaciones
apuntan a que ahora mismo en torno al 25% de
las oficinas de la ciudad podrían estar vacías.
Y, ¿sabéis qué está provocando esto? Pues,
por un lado, que las calles estén cada vez
más vacías, lo que está haciendo que algunas
tiendas y restaurantes que vivían de los
trabajadores de las oficinas estén cerrando.
Por otro lado, imaginaos que de repente os ofrecen
teletrabajar, ¿os quedaríais en una ciudad donde
el alquiler consume casi todos vuestros
ingresos? Puede que alguno si lo hicierais
por ciertos motivos, pero seguro, seguro que
muchos os iríais a vivir a lugares más baratos.
Pues bien, justo esto es lo que también
está pasando en San Francisco. Muchos
profesionales se están yendo a vivir a
otras ciudades e, incluso, a otros estados.
Pero no solo los trabajadores
están intentando irse,
muchas empresas también están
barajando esta misma idea.
Y es que, veréis, al teletrabajo y los altos
costes de los alquileres, los segundos más
caros de todo el país, se le une también un factor
importante para las empresas: la presión fiscal.
El 59% de los ejecutivos de las
industrias tecnológicas de San
Francisco consideran que los impuestos
y regulaciones tanto de la ciudad como
del estado son excesivos. Pese
a lo cual no dejan de aumentar.
Vamos, que San Francisco también
se está enfrentando a un creciente
éxodo de personas y empresas.
Es algo todavía muy incipiente,
pero el riesgo está sobre la mesa. Y eso
es lo que explica noticias como esta:
N6 (Este es el plan de S.F. para acabar
con la burocracia y construir
82.000 viviendas. SFChronicle)
Inseguridad, drogas y altos costes
de la vida parecen estar haciendo
que San Francisco se una a una lista de
viejas glorias como Detroit o San José.
Por supuesto, no van a bajar los
brazos tan pronto. El gobierno de
la ciudad ya ha conseguido el apoyo del
gobernador de California, Gavin Newsom,
para desplegar una fuerza antidroga. Además, los
ciudadanos de San Francisco ya han sustituido
al desastroso Boudin por Brooke Jenkins, una
nueva fiscal del distrito mucho más estricta.
Y no solo eso, también cuenta con
el apoyo de la administración Biden,
que ha presentado la Estrategia
Nacional para el Control de Drogas.
Pero sea como sea, si algo parece claro es que San
Francisco no está atravesando sus mejores momentos
y la pregunta es: ¿creéis que la nueva fiscal
logrará reducir la inseguridad de la ciudad?
¿De qué forma podría hacer frente San Francisco a
la epidemia del fentanilo? ¿Tendría que intervenir
el gobierno federal? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios. Como siempre,
no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.